monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues nous
venons d'apprendre à l'instant pendant
que s'exprimait le premier ministre
qu'un attentat d'une gravité extrême
s'est produit à nice où d'après les
informations parcellaires dont je
dispose au moins une personne aurait été
assassiné tandis que d'autres seraient
je parle au conditionnel de là où je
suis je n'ai pas plus d'informations
quoi qu'il en soit je vous demande dans
ces circonstances tragiques d'observer
une minute de silence en solidarité à
l'égard de la ou des victimes
évidemment de l'ensemble de ses proches
la séance est suspendue pour quelques
minutes